just I just wish we could call people  howlies out here I know because it's a  fun word also you guys adopted the word  Hapa we adopted it the true Hapa is like  half Hawaiian blood with like mixed with  other people now it's just like half  white half asian now yeah Japanese or I  thought it was Japanese because Hapa  just means half yeah but it's not the  right term to use either the correct  term is called a freak  [Laughter]  I think they call them hafu in Japanese  but what my grandma used to call them is  basically oh that's like a Filipino  thing it's like going oh no oh my God  yeah the direct translation is a kid  made from love because the concept is  you must really love each other to  violence isn't every kid made from Love